- - Impossible d'ignorer le brut
dedes avions qui atterrissent
ouou qui décollent.
C C'est la réalité des résidens
ququi habitent en périphérie
dede l'aéroport et dans le nord
dede Montréal, non seulement
lele jour, mais aussi la nuit.
ANANTOINE BÉCOTTE, vice-préside,
LeLes Pollués de Montréal-Trudeu
- - Il y en a plus. Avant, c'étt
4-4-5 la nuit, des fois aucun.
PuPuis maintenant, c'est réguli,
llà, 10-15.
- - À Montréal, les heures
d'd'exploitation des gros
apappareils, qui pèsent plus
dede 45 tonnes et qui sont plus
brbruyants, sont limitées.
L Leur décollage est interdit
enentre minuit et 7 h, et
leleur atterrissage l'est
auaussi entre 1 h et 7 h.
M Mais selon n une compilation
efeffectuée par un des membres u
grgroupes les Pollués de Montré-
TrTrudeau, 15 avions ont obtenu
unune exemption chaque jour
enen moyenne entre le 13 ett
lele 26 juin pour décollerer
ouou atterrir en pleine e nuit.
- - Tu peux pas t'asseoir dans
tata cour parce que les avions
papassent continuellement le jo.
PuPuis la nuit, bien, tu te fais
réréveiller par les avions.
AlAlors ça fait une situation
dede vie très désagréable. Alor,
leles gens, qu'est-ce qu'ils fo?
BiBien, quand ils n'en peuvent
plplus, bien, ils mettent
unune pancarte à vendre,
pupuis ils déménagent.
- - Aéroports de Montréal admet
ququ'un plus grand nombre
d'd'exemptions qu'à l'habitude t
étété données depuis le début
dede l'été. Elles peuvent être
acaccordées s en raison
dedes conditions météo, comme
àà la mi-juin , alors que des
ororages violents ont provoqué
l'l'annulation de 160 vols.
M Mais c'est surtout le manquee
pepersonnel et la désorganisatin
dadans le secteur aérien, source
dede retards, qui sont en cause.
MEMEHRAN EBRAHIMI, dir., Obs.
ininter., aviation, ÉSG, UQAM
- - Tant qu'on ne peut pas
ababsorber ça, on n'a qu'une
sosolution : soit les vols ne
papartent pas, soit les volsls
papartent au moment où
lele vol est prêt à parartir.
- - Selon un organisme qui anale
lala pollution sonore, le bruit
auau sol pourrait être atténué
sisi les avions amorçaient
leleur virage après le décollage
àà une plus haute altitude.
BIBILL MAVRIDIS, fondateur,
MoMontréal dB
- - Je sais qu'un avion qui mone
àà 5000 pieds va toucher les ges
susur les terres de Montréal mos
ququ'un avion à 300 pieds.
JeJe pense que ce changement pet
aiaider beaucoup.
- - Mais entretemps, en plus
dede pénaliser les voyageurs,
lele chaos dans les aéroports
pépénalise aussi ceux qui habitt
auaux alentours.
I Ici Olivier Bachand,